[Music]
before George Floyd was killed this
pandemic was infected with racism Asian
Canadians have been targeted yelled at
spat at and worse people lashing out at
them in the mistaken belief that somehow
their Asian descent makes them
responsible for the novel coronavirus as
Robin Gill reports that is reopening old
wounds and ESA's flower shop in
Toronto's East End has been in his
family for 48 years
passed on to him from his parents he
grew up in the multi-ethnic neighborhood
and had never experienced racism then he
noticed his customers acting strangely
when Kovan 19 surfaced people started
getting a little bit more apprehensive
about coming inside
after the whole Luhan thing earlier in
the year in the news people started kind
of questioning was it safe to approach
me anymore just because of my Asian
background
he was even asked if he had ever been to
Wuhan the virus originated in Wuhan
China and that fact has fuelled attacks
against Chinese Canadians like Trixie
Ling she was just going for a walk when
she was confronted by a young white man
who called her names and then spit on
her I actually felt really angry that
was probably the strongest emotion I
felt angry that she'd been singled out
in this humiliating way based on her
racial background a lot of these racist
incident that has increasingly appear a
lot of them is is done by white folks
and so when it's that aggression and
racism against people of color there's
this odd ring of you don't belong here
the Vancouver Police Department says
there's been a 600 percent increase in
reports of hate crimes targeting the
Asian community whether they're of
Chinese Korean or Japanese descent a
woman punched at a bus stop an older man
pushed out of a store Chinatown sprayed
with graffiti British Columbia's anti
racism Network doesn't think there's a
rise in hate crimes it's always been
there more people are just coming
forward we're in a time right now when
people
our feeling more open about expressing
their feelings their exposing their
racist ideas the anti Asian sentiment
also labeled the Yellow Peril is
entrenched in public health emergencies
going back to when the Chinese first
started immigrating to Canada
Sandra Hyde is a Montreal professor
whose research focuses on the
correlation between pandemics and how
different cultures get targeted during
health care's in a pandemic where we
have no cure no vaccine people are
afraid and they want a place blame and
it's easy to place blame on somebody
else who's different than you the
Chinese were blamed for the 2003 SARS
crisis because it first appeared in
Guangdong a Pittsburgh paper felt
compelled to publish this controversial
political cartoon that in 2020 a major
Toronto newspaper took it a step further
and Canada's top doctor found herself in
the crosshairs of racist rhetoric by a
member of parliament does she work for
Canada or for China it doesn't help when
celebrities get in on the action
take this racist branch posted on rocker
Bryan Adams Instagram it comes from
China then there's the influence of the
US president Donald Trump has been
deliberately disparaging calling it the
Chinese virus it's always an open season
and I think recently it's been easier to
be an open season because of the link
between Asia and the epidemic you know
coming coming from China people like
Trump calling it the Chinese virus or
the Wuhan virus without understanding
that you know viruses know no borders
Iran too was a hot spot for the new
coronavirus but the Iranian Canadian
community kept a lid on any attacks in
terms of an through Ron Ian's sentiments
there are and actions there are the
cases that I'm aware of but generally
speaking the community's not looking for
conflict and they just want to let it
and we're trying to encourage them to
come forward and speak out and feel
comfortable to us the outbreak of racism
is so palpable in BC that the
left-handed governor launched an anti
racism campaign but sadly our success
has been marred by a troubling increase
in race-based violence
different together is aimed at quelling
the hate but it's a challenge with the
overt anti Chinese language coming from
south of the border
it's a topic that people need to be
talking about and we need to be
normalizing the discussion about racism
what's happened in the United States
Donald Trump has normalized
the the ability to be racist and in
Canada we need to do things differently
we need to normalize this discussion
anti racism advocates believe it starts
with education in elementary schools and
should continue in the workplace you
have to make it mandatory just like
universities are now making workshops on
sexual misconduct mandatory I think you
don't set it up as if it's an option
Trixie Ling knows she's now going to be
a voice for change to end systemic
racism it's not just a one-off
individual thing is actually a
collective structural problem that we
have and Andy Hsu has a message for
anyone who wants to turn this pandemic
into a cultural war this virus has no
face it could happen to anyone and we
shouldn't be afraid of each other to
help guide us through some things to
combat this I'm joined by Professor
Carol liao she teaches law u BC with a
focus on business law ethics and
corporate governance
she's a second-generation Taiwanese
Canadian professional Yale thanks for
joining us you know we like to believe
in Canada that were enlightened and
tolerant and that racist acts are
isolated what is your sense of how
pervasive anti-asian racism is in Canada
you know well there's a false sense of
Canadian exceptionalism that forgets our
very racist history but we need to be
honest about colonialism the Chinese
head tax and exclusion act Japanese
internment
ongoing anti-black and anti indigenous
violence and over incarceration you know
we desperately want to see our past is
disconnected from our present like we
reach some sort of self-determined
island and we don't like to acknowledge
systemic racism right it's much easier
for people to be disgusted with hate
crimes you know of course we're against
that and to compartmentalize acts of
violence it's isolated events until they
finally come to a head like they are in
the US but it's much harder for us to
admit our own racist tendencies both
conscious and unconscious you know I've
lost count of the number of people that
have told me that they are colorblind or
don't see race there's a lot of
defensiveness and it's just not
something I find people are generally
open to talking about here even though
there is prevalent casual and systemic
racism that exists so when it comes to
this pandemic in COBIT 19 how does it
compare to anti-asian racism that was
linked to SARS 18 years ago is it worse
now well you know I don't have to even
look back to SARS to be reminded of anti
Asian sentiment you know in the past few
years as Vancouver's housing prices have
skyrocketed you know there's been a lot
of collateral racism I'll be having
coffee with a group and overhear someone
saying they don't want to sell to an
Asian person and I'm right there you
know and I had a man shout of a shil
slur in my open car window as he drove
by and my three young children were
behind me and heard it all and that was
pre-pandemic
so you know this anti Asian sentiment
none of it is surprising to me you know
it was all predictable with some
politicians practically inviting it and
you know given the protracted period of
copán where the the end seems so far
away and with the widespread suffering
of so many people and this convenience
of misdirected blame on not just Asian
but any Asian looking person yes it is
worse there's overt racism we know and
there's unconscious bias you do training
sessions to help companies overcome
unconscious bias can you explain in
simple terms what that is I'm sure a
simple example is how we hear someone
with an English accent and they
they sound smart yet research has shown
any other accent and we judge more
harshly
you know empirical studies also show
time and again how women and people of
color have to work harder to establish
competence in the workplace and prove it
over and over again so you know the
increased anti-asian racism it should
remind asian Canadians that we've often
benefited from a system that's rooted in
anti blackness and how much the model
minority position it's only used to
bolster the status quo until it's taken
away and you know in Vancouver in
particular I hear people claim there
can't be that much anti black racism
here given how many black people they
perceive are in Vancouver you know and
I'd like to ask what is the right number
for people to recognize racism you know
I've also heard so many people
expressing surprise that there is anti
Asian racism given how many Asian people
there are it seems we're either too few
to matter or too many to matter so
what's the right number before we're
willing to recognize these things and
what are the obligations do you think of
business leaders and politicians not to
enable racism not to be complicit in it
well you know representation matters
take a look at the makeup of your
leadership the numbers are abysmal in
the corporate sector less than six
percent of board seats are comprised of
people of color and less than 1% are
held by indigenous peoples you know
organizations should commit to
anti-racist biased training and it
cannot be a one-off either
there must be education and deliberate
ongoing interventions from both an
individual and organizational level you
know they should amplify marginalized
voices they should have whistle
whistleblower protections and non
retribution policies demonstrable
inclusion practices each organization of
course has their own issues but there
needs to be some introspection on the
power dynamics within each institution
do you think this pandemic could be a
teachable moment about racism or could
it make it more pervasive you know it's
behold on all of us to recognize that we
where we're situated in all of this we
can't have public ambivalence you know
my heart's been just broken too many
times watching the uptick in overt
racism caused by very live issues in the
city and we need to think about what we
can do long term to address the systemic
racism within our communities and
hopefully now with everything that's
happening we can spend less time
discussing whether racism is real and
exists within our institutions and focus
more on what can be done about it
you know and change is the result of
concerted persistent and ongoing efforts
of many individuals and I collectively
move us towards change and you know time
doesn't change things deliberate actions
do and we're living history right now so
it's time for us to step up and listen
to those seeking change